I hadn't Rodriguez what are you doing we
didn't beat the buzzer that's it let's
try that again
that's right Rodriguez here on the set
of one day at a time what are you doing
here I'm here to have a good time people
know I'm here as a fan first of all of
the show and Claudia Colette and and
Norman Lear who originated it and and
and so much of his other works I mean I
really just like I'm excited to be here
really happy so you're gonna be
officially guest starring season four of
one day at a time
tell me are you in cos this is costume
this is hair this is makeup this is
wardrobe ladies and gentlemen I love it
yes tell us about your character and
what his deal is
so my deal is I got sort of recall it
catfished by Lydia and she's trying to
she's trying to step and I'll be up on a
date
as as every good nosy mother does
because they care what she does and
we're better to find it than randomly on
the internet nowadays right and so I'm
here I get lured into her her plan and I
sit down and get get to know Lydia a
little bit I don't want to spoil it too
much but I am Lydia is not quite honest
about who she is
shoppers just save that shocking to hear
that you know you're sharing the screen
with forces like Justina Machado
a legend like and one of my oldest
friends in LA I
oh yeah just the Internet go away where
you know each other for years so you get
to reconnect with Justyna you get to
share the screen with Rita Moreno what
does that experience like well I can't
tell you yet cuz it hasn't happened why
I can I can imagine that it's gonna be
it's gonna be a lot of fun
I mean first of all in honor and so to
spend some time on screen with Rita will
be a real treat I know that my family is
going to get every bit as much of a kick
out of that as I am so that that's
that's a really that's a treat I'm
excited about that as a father to two
young girls what does it mean to you to
have a show like one day at a time where
they can see themselves represented on
screen it's a show that maybe in a few
years when they're a little older you
can understand better so you guys can
sit down on a Tuesday night and watch it
together yeah absolutely I you know it
what it means to be a part of shows like
this because there are so few of them
really I mean on so many layers I mean
look I'm the most broad layer like just
to have a great family comedy that is
addressing issues between parents and
children and you know single mothers and
parent-child relationships of different
generations you know I think it's so
important there's just there's not
enough of this being intelligently
addressed and you know and then on top
of that being poked fun at so that
people can actually let go and learn the
lessons we need to learn to grow as
people so for that I think that it has
tremendous value you know again know
that that's the legacy of Norman Lear
you know he's always been so good at
doing that putting the mirror on us and
you know allowing us to look at
ourselves honestly and and laugh at the
truth that we see you know and that's
that's the beauty of comedy when it's
well done and I think this show is like
I said just really living up to all of
that so it's the the show is important
to be on the air and the fact that it's
a Latin family when there's so little
representation on television of Latin
families that you know that that's
really just a wonderful added bonus I
think you know for people that aren't
used to seeing themselves on TV in that
way totally I mean as a girl dad doing
this kind of work are you cognizant of
the roles you're choosing because you
want them to be able to watch see
themselves represented how important is
that to you yeah I mean I have to say
I'm probably selfish with that first
because even if there was a role that I
might not want them to see but it spoke
to something in me
I would have to take it because you know
it's my life sorry girls but I but but
those thoughts do cross my mind in a way
that they never did of course you know I
actually like did you think about that
do think about that now you know just in
terms of what I would want them to see
for my girls and for anybody else that's
going to see it I mean the characters
that that I am choosing to play lately I
think there is more thought and more put
into you know what that represents for
the people watching hey come over come
join our Chad please help me no not me
Oh a different atom now you're breaking
my heart wasn't even me I heard how
about that love you babe love her I love
that Queen instead of a toast I want to
make a promise
can we please promise that no matter
where we go after this that we keep
this feeling in our hearts after 15
seasons of Criminal Minds what's going
through your mind how are you feeling
well I've had time to lament and get
over we actually finished all of the
final episodes almost it's not quite a
year actually probably about nine months
ago and so we we've kept up contact on a
very regular basis because we all miss
each other so we've got a group text
that was like almost almost daily
somebody chimes in about something okay
what goes down in those group chat I can
never tell you have to be there I'm
sorry I would love to share some of that
but a lot of laughs a lot of making fun
of each other oh it's pretty equal
actually everybody yeah everybody
everybody shows up big maybe paget
Brewster pageant might be the ringleader
of that oh it's close so even though
this series is wrapped you guys are
still very much communicating like a
family all the time
yeah I actually I just talked to Erica
Messer yesterday you know just keep it
up this is such a great group of people
I just have really really enjoyed that
little bit of time that I got with
members three seasons for me but I'm so
grateful that I that I got to be a part
of that group what did you steal from
the set did you take home any mementos
you know what I did I took I took a
little nameplate that just had SSA
Alba's on it that I was like all right
up with this I put this on a desk
somewhere at some point in my life yeah
I was gonna say did you have when I grow
up and I have a desk I was thinking
since we're gonna work together anymore
maybe take you to dinner
yeah yeah yeah it's gonna be the end so
you're not for now oh oh I don't know
the show's doing so well in the ratings
that I would not be surprised I mean
maybe I'm being overly optimistic in
some way well I don't know maybe the
show gets you know revived somehow I
would love for them to put the paddles
on it and bring us back for a limited
run or something to get the gang back
together we'll see I don't know it's so
you're you're down if there's a second
life on this I'm hopeful I'm hopeful
[Music]